for today's classic interview we're
going back to November of 2014 my
interview with Phil Gibbons about the
death penalty this is particularly
relevant now because even though over
time we've seen a reduction in the
number of states that have the death
penalty we have had a couple of recent
death penalty related stories including
the situation in Arkansas where there
were a number of executions done I still
think of the death penalty frequently as
an important issue for the United States
for a country at our level of
development and there has been no better
time in the last certainly couple of
years than now to go back to my 2014
interview with Phil Gibbons let's get
into that I'm joined today by Phillip
Gibbons who is the director of the
documentary film the devil and the death
penalty it revisits the case of Lawrence
Bittaker a convicted serial murderer and
child killer who's been on death row at
San Quentin in California since 1981
Philip tell us how did you first get
into doing a film about this I lived in
LA for Mohsen Redondo Beach and a lot of
the residents longtime residents there
told me the story of Lawrence Bittaker
and such a beautiful Pacific Coast
setting it was hard for me to believe in
something that horrible could happen and
most of these conversations would
conclude with me asking okay well
Lawrence Bittaker was sentenced to death
obviously he was executed or died in
prison because this happened in 1979 and
the answer I would get would be know
very much alive on on death row at San
Quentin when I would ask for what's
going on with his Appeals people would
just shrug their shoulders and as far
back as late 90s I started to
investigate exactly what was going on
with Lawrence Bittaker hence the film
and what was the reasoning for why in
spite being on death row since 1981 he
had not has not been executed is it
because of appeals or is there some
other explanation well that's how you
wind up with a 75 minute documentary but
I think it's important for your viewers
to understand that all executions in the
state of California have been on hold
since 2006
Lawrence bittakers case like many cases
in California just because there are
many people when I say many there's at
least 100 or 200 people
been on death row since the 80s and only
13 people since 1979 have been executed
there are now seven hundred and fifty
people on California's death row again
dating back as far as 1980 and that has
to do with a stalemate between the
appellate courts both federal and state
and the voters who who basically took
this out of the hands of the state
courts and by referendum have made it
impossible for the states to get rid of
capital punishment unless another
popular referendum is passed doing that
the last attempt to try to get rid of
capital punishments by popular
referendum failed in 2012 two questions
regarding the cost of all this first of
all if we didn't have this sort of
moratorium that's going on right now
what the what is the cost comparison
between someone in prison without parole
for life versus a death penalty
execution or does it depend actually on
how long it takes to make that execution
happen it kind of depends on who you
speak with during the referendum
election the the legislative analyst
came up with a number of one hundred and
thirty million dollars annually spent I
mean that would pencil out to a to a her
prisoner type of cost but I would say
that just for the sake of argument
that's a number that I think people
should try to wrap their arms around but
also to put that number in perspective
because abolitionists involved obviously
use cost as an argument to get rid of
capital punishment but for instance the
annual budget of the Los Angeles Police
Department is 1.4 billion dollars the
annual budget of the Los Angeles County
Sheriff's Department is 1.2 billion
dollars so so putting that you know
giving you an order of magnitude yes it
is hundreds of millions of dollars on an
annual basis but but you know the mere
cost in a state that has a hundred nine
billion dollar annual budget which seem
pretty insignificant when you're
discussing what a lot of these people
are done which is something they get
into later on yes so as you as you did
research and talk to people around this
story talk to us a little bit about what
you uncovered with regard to what would
be achieved via the execution of
Lawrence Bittaker in other words were
there
diffic individuals who felt that his
execution would in any way be justice
rather than revenge you know again it
basically depends on your perspective
and as I'm sure you're aware capital
punishment really just engenders a lot
of very emotional responses I think my
personal opinion is well I'm very
ambivalent about capital punishment
especially as practiced in places like
Texas and Florida and Georgia California
is very different and the thing that
it's a very rare individual only 2% of
individuals charged with homicide
basically ever are subjected they've
even a capital punishment trial so the
people who wind up on death row like
Lawrence Bittaker have done particularly
heinous things and so so the issue
becomes you know for me personally what
is the standard I mean what is the line
that you're going to cross in his case
when we basically kidnapped like for the
co-conspirator kidnapped tortured and
raped five teenage girls in a fashion
that the prosecutor who prosecuted both
men described as worse than Manson we're
talking about a level of depravity here
that's quite unusual and quite
dissimilar shall we say to say the state
of Texas what would it accomplish I mean
in a philosophical sense you know you
can have that argument I think you can
have a whole semester of a classic Cal
Berkeley to discuss that question I
can't
to me personally I find me to be so
heinous that basically you know that it
almost it's common sense that's an
individual I can by the way it's a
totally unrepentant psychopath who would
would basically that the only really I
think common sense thing to do but the
only thing that would make sense in
terms of punishment for this guy it was
made it clear that he couldn't care less
about what's good and about you know
other people is execution because that's
basically the only thing that will ever
get this person's attention yeah I don't
I don't think I agree with you in a
couple of senses number one having to
spend you know you execute this guy the
lights go off and that's it whatever
whatever punishment whatever he has to
deal with by sitting in that cell for
the rest of his life and rotting is
eliminated he is relieved of that as
opposed to saying you know but
psychopaths or not he's going to sit
there and he's going to do
nothing for the rest of his life but
putting that aside for a second Philip
when we think about this when you made
this argument of this was a particularly
heinous crime this is a serial murderer
and child killer and one of the most
interesting arguments I've heard against
what California does which is reserving
it only for the most extreme cases is
that it is devaluing to the victims of a
lone murderer in other words if you have
a murderer who killed one person and
California says that's not heinous
enough for us to put that person to
death isn't it in any in a sense
devaluing or an insult to the victims of
the families of the victims of someone
who only killed one person you're saying
if only one person died that's not
really as bad as if they killed multiple
people well I think I think that again
we live in California and surprisingly
by the way on an annual basis when you
compare it to Texas for instance Texas
in 2000 I think it was 2012 had 10 death
sentences handed out by juries in
California there were 24 so I think
though to address your specific question
if you if you got into an estate like
California the 35 million people you
started to basically have jurors that
were convicting people are lone murders
and sentencing to death the number of
people who would go to death row in
California would be staggering I mean
but hold on I can feel it because now
you're making a logistical argument
you're saying now now first you let me
let me just let me see if I can wrap my
head around this sure first you said
that in really heinous cases like this
one you think the death penalty is the
only logical solution the only logical
punishment but when I said doesn't that
in some way tell the victims the
families of the victims who were just
killed individually that their victim
their family member was not worth enough
for the perpetrator to get the death
penalty you say well now logistically it
would be complex those are two different
arguments well they are and yet and yet
I would say again there's there's the
sort of the philosophical discussion
we're having not as if we're we're on to
yeah you know I'm not sure they were on
two different sides of the spectrum in
fact someone who in California adhere to
the idea that even people who murder one
person should also be punishable based
on the interest of the victims families
I understand that viewpoint I'm just I
guess what I'm getting to is having
studied this the reality if that ever
happens is just non-existent it's just
that the mindset of juries in this state
is such that that again the people who
wind up getting these types of sentences
are people who are again so beyond the
pale yeah but but again the practicality
of it I don't think is a factor when
we're talking about what what is right
or wrong for me
fill up the issues are number one I
don't believe in the state putting
people to death in other words I I
believe that it is wrong for the state
or federal government to decide this
crime now is going to allow us to
legally kill this person I'm against
that number two when I look at what
other countries still have the death
penalty and what other countries have
chosen to get rid of it and I look at
what else those same countries have done
right and wrong the u.s. is really an
outlier in terms of the developed
wealthy nations and maintaining this and
to me that's a real concern and the
number three we've seen no evidence
whatsoever I mean literally no evidence
that the death penalty works as a
deterrent to people committing crimes so
I've decided for me personally that this
is an outdated retrograde practice that
serves no judicial purpose and is more
an issue of revenge rather than justice
that's me you know I totally understand
and that's that's a very eloquently
stated perspective and frankly it's a
perspective that it's all of those
things resonate with me and yet after
making a film of this kind you almost
you become so frustrated because again
when you read about people like Barnes
Bittaker you understand their
personalities it may not make any real
everything you say they potentially be
or even may may be actually true in a
sense of real practicality in terms of
what we should do and how we should
proceed again there's something about
him as an individual or others like them
that strikes such an emotional chord
that I think
I think you can understand the other
viewpoint that there are people who
don't feel overweight of course and what
you're saying actually I've admitted
that I can imagine specific situations
where someone I know is killed where I
might have an emotional reaction as you
indicated that makes me want that person
dead but I feel in the same way that you
just said confirming my suspicions that
those would be emotional reactions that
make me want revenge rather than an
application of justice by the judicial
system well the other the other aspect
to their David that my film gets into is
putting aside again the you know the two
sort of philosophical viewpoints we've
discussed the other the other aspect
that this is I was media dealing with
this issue in a state and also how is
the judiciary and the apparatus that is
in charge of this because California has
this situation where quite frankly both
the judiciary and the bureaucracy are
active in it in a fashion that is
despite anyone's philosophical viewpoint
the rules of law young state has
ratified four times by popular
referendum as for for this to be the
punishment and whether whether you agree
with that behind the scenes a small
group of the lead people have done
everything possible to frustrate that
yeah but it feel like that that argument
doesn't resonate with me because the the
anti-gay bigots make the same argument
when it comes to voting against same-sex
marriage and we can still a value we can
still say that you can't vote a popular
vote can't determine everything and
there are certain cases where things we
could just determine things are either
immoral unethical against the law
unconstitutional etc so while I'm not
making those specific arguments here the
fact that a referendum happened should
not ultimately decide what what is it is
that takes place with every single issue
but that's probably an argument for a
different day because unfortunately we
are at a time I do want to recommend to
people to film the devil and the death
penalty whatever your position about the
death penalty
Philip Gibbons this film will be of
interest to you and I can't thank you
enough for being here today it's my
pleasure and I would just like to
interject that it is available currently
on iTunes and Xbox 360 and through my
website double of the death penalty